[Musique]
la planète terre dans un futur proche
autour de la terre l'espace est polluée
il dérive en orbite d'innombrables
débris des millions de fragments de
tailles variées incontrôlable vieux
satellite hors d'usagé pièces de
véhicules spatiaux ces débris entoure la
planète et il n'y a aucun moyen de les
récupérer
les accidents vont se multiplier les
vols habités et risque de devenir trop
dangereux et les communications par
satellite vont se détériorer les
systèmes de navigation gps pourrait
devenir de moins en moins fiables
internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse nous
gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie tout cela pourrait devenir
totalement inutilisable
des fragments dans cette église se sont
écrasés soir andré vaque à ses
occupations qu'ensuite forces cosmiques
se sont littéralement abattus sur le
village de baguette c'est beau je
prenais du bois et à peine me suis-je
détourner de la pile qu'un grand
claquement s'est fait entendre comme un
petit fou et la maison d'un drake rivaux
rodtchenko se trouve rue des cosmonautes
une nuit de décembre le toit de son
grenier a été traversé par un fragment
d'un satellite de télécommunications à
usage civil et militaire meridian lancé
depuis le cosmodrome russe de plessetsk
situé à plus de 3000 km de là j'ai
regardé à travers la fenêtre en
éclairant avec ma torche
je n'allais pas rentrer là-dedans et
avait une sorte de grosse sphère jussieu
les habitants de la région de
novossibirsk on trouvait dit fragments
d'un satellite pesant entre 500 g et 2
kg ils en ont pris quelques
photographies peu de temps après les
agents du ministère des situations
d'urgence ont emmené les débris
[Musique]
le meridian n'a pas atteint son orbite
finale et a fini par retomber devenant
un simple tas de ferraille
si la panne était survenu quelques
minutes plus tard en orbite le satellite
serait devenu un débris spatial pouvant
causer des dommages considérables des
millions de dollars en pertes
matérielles des pertes en vies humaines
une crise internationale ou même une
guerre
[Musique]
en 1957 l'urss lança le premier
satellite artificiel
les états unis suivirent en 1958 trois
ans plus tard l'union soviétique envoyé
le premier homme dans l'espace le début
de l'ère spatiale coïncide avec la
grande accélération
c'est ainsi que les scientifiques
appellent les changements qui ont eu
lieu à l'échelle de la planète
la population mondiale l'économie le
nombre de véhicules la consommation de
papier
l'utilisation d'engrais ne cesse
d'augmenter ainsi que la concentration
de dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
la fréquence des inondations et le
nombre d'espèces animales menacées les
années 1950 sont donc considérés comme
le début de l'anthropocène soit l'ère de
l'homme une nouvelle ère géologique dans
l'histoire de la terre il existe un
terme
entrepose fer qui désigne l'extension de
l'entrepôt scène cela comprend non
seulement notre planète mais également
tout satellite ou autre engin spatial
qui est envoyé dans l'espace et sort des
limites de l'entrepôt ce faire
[Musique]
à l'observatoire astrophysique de crime
et les frontières de l'entrepôt ce faire
sont surveillés en particulier les
débris spatiaux suivant les orbites les
plus éloignés en vingt ans les
chercheurs de l'observatoire ont détecté
plus d'un millier de débris
les objets que vassily romillonne cf
découvre se trouve si loin qu'on a du
mal à les discerner sans même parler de
les décrire dit cet objet mesure dans
les dix centimètres et se trouve à
environ trente six mille kilomètres de
la terre il est gris foncé séparation du
module orbital du lanceur confirmer en
2010 est le lanceur russe proton m a
placé en orbite le satellite de
communication chinois asiasat 9 le
satellite fonctionnaient comme prévu
mais rapidement les astronomes on
trouvait à une altitude de 20 mille
kilomètres très objets situés non loin
d'une partie de la fusée sur les
photographies de vassili rotchev vous
pouvez voir le propulseur lui-même et
six petits points qui sont en réalité
des fragments c'est comme ça que de
nouveaux débris spatiaux se forme
après le lancement d'un satellite la
plupart des débris n'ont pas encore été
repéré mais au regard de la fréquence à
laquelle on trouve quelque chose en
orbite
on peut être sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup
si on prend en compte les fragments de
quelques millimètres bien y en avoir un
million lorsque l'homme s'est envolé
pour la première fois pour l'espace des
douzaines de satellites circuler déjà
autour de la terre mise en orbite par
l'urss et les états unis
les américains ont créé leur premier
système de navigation par satellite
précurseur du gps moderne
le 29 juin 1961 un étage de la fusée qui
a placé en orbite le satellite transit
4a a explosé faisant 296 fragments qui
sont devenus les premiers débris
spatiaux de l'histoire cependant
personne ne s'en est préoccupé
une collision avec une particule d'un
centimètre qui se déplace à une vitesse
de 10 km par seconde équivaut à
l'énergie d'une collision avec une
voiture pesant une tonne allant à 100
km/heure 1968 l'union soviétique procède
au premier essai d'une arme anti
satellite
le vaisseau spatial soviétique cosmos
249 et détruit 110 fragments reste en
orbite
au total 2000 objets hors de contrôle et
de tailles différentes sont alors déjà
répertoriés
à l'époque les débris spatiaux semblait
être un problème secondaire
les scientifiques étaient tournés en
ridicule ces petits fragments en orbite
ne constitue aucun danger réel ni pour
les gens ni pour les satellites
après tout ils n'étaient pas nombreux et
pouvait brûler en rentrant dans
l'atmosphère terrestre
[Musique]
l'employé de la nasa donald kessler a
commencé à envisager les risques posés
par les débris spatiaux au milieu des
années 70 si on parle des fragments de
10 cm et plus il y a dix huit mille
objets catalogués et je dois souligner
qu'il ne s'agit là que des fragments de
10 cm et plus 5 mais si on essaie de
compter les objets de moins d'un
centimètre
c'est comme chercher une aiguille dans
une botte de foin il y en aurait plus de
100000 et quant aux fragments d'un
millimètre on ne pourrait même pas les
compter
car les plus petites particules qu'on a
pu détecter mesurer 3 mm et il y en a
des centaines de milliers on doit ces
centaines de millions de fragments
divers des rives d'olt côtés de quelque
2000 satellite artificiel
tout comme sur terre la zone la plus
polluée est la plus encombrée
c'est ici l'orbité terrestre basse près
de la surface de la planète
ici on peut espérer que ces débris
brûleront en rentrant un jour dans
l'atmosphère
dans l'orbité terrestre basse à une
altitude allant jusqu'à 600 700 km un
objet peut durer quelques décennies
concernant les satellites
géostationnaires ont ce que nous
utilisons à la maison au recevoir des
signaux par satellite pour la télévision
numérique et internet
il circule à une distance de près de
36000 km de la terre et tout ce qui se
trouve là bas il restera pour toujours
il semble qu'une décharge spatiale se
soit formée autour de la terre et que
personne ne puisse la faire disparaître
qui plus est elle ne cesse de grandir en
1978 donald kessler a pris conscience
d'un risque imminent
un jour viendra où les débris n'iront
pas seulement se heurter au satellite en
orbite mais causeront aussi des cascades
de collisions qui produiront à leur tour
des libres et secondaire ce scénario
d'apocalypse spatiale a été appelée
syndrome de kessler et donald kessler
n'a eu de cesse d'appeler à intensifier
les efforts pour éviter une catastrophe
la réaction de l'un de mes chefs a été
négative
quand on lui a dit qu'il fallait lancer
un programme il a répondu mais vous n'y
arriverez jamais avec un programme
pareil il faut une coopération
internationale la coopération
internationale était impossible dans le
contexte de la guerre froide
de plus l'humanité n'était pas
réellement consciente des risques
les premiers téléphones satellitaires
fonctionnait bien la télévision était
devenu la norme pour des millions de
personnes
le signal atteignait les zones les plus
reculées depuis l'espace il était
difficile d'imaginer que tout cela
puisse disparaître en un instant à cause
de quelques débris en orbite
[Musique]
en 1985
l'armée américaine a décidé de tester
une arme anti satellite en détruisant un
vieux satellite astrophysics longue à la
nasa nous avons officiellement protesté
contre ce test eun sun ont planifié
alors de lancer une station spatiale
dans un avenir assez proche et après un
tel test il nous serait obligatoire de
mettre des blindages supplémentaires sur
la station spatiale
les militaires ne nous ont pas cru ils
ont dit vous ne savez pas ce qui va
arriver et j'ai objecté comment ça ça
peut tout simplement faire un trou et
voilà tout
l'essai fut un succès mais le satellite
pris pour cible s'est transformé en
débris 285 nouveaux fragments dangereux
se sont retrouvés en orbite et bien sûr
ils ont changé d'avis après 5 ou on en a
déduit qu'il fallait renoncer à
effectuer ce genre d c'est parce que
c'est un très mauvais moyen d'éliminer
un satellite al
[Musique]
1991 un débris spatial un vieux
satellites soviétiques cosmos 955 s'est
approché de la navette discovery
mais l'équipage l'a remarqué à temps la
navette spatiale à manoeuvrer et appuie
éviter la collision
cinq ans plus tard le satellite
militaire français cerise a été heurté
par un morceau de la fusée ariane
c'était la première collision entre un
vaisseau spatial opérationnel et un
débris il n'ya alors plus de doute quant
aux risques que représentent les débris
spatiaux de nouvelles questions se sont
donc posées qui sera le prochain à être
heurtés à quel moment les désastres
spatiaux causeront t-il des problèmes
sur terre
notre estimation à ce jour et que tous
les dix ans environ
une collision entre deux grands objets
va survenir c'est à dire une catastrophe
il y aura une collision entre des
fragments plus petit et un gros objet
tous les 5 en 2009 les deux tiers de
l'humanité utilise des téléphones
portables les cartes utilisant les
images satellites sont parmi les
applications les plus populaires
la majorité de la population de la
planète c'est à quoi ressemble la terre
depuis l'espace
les populations des régions éloignées où
il n'y a pas de couverture mobile
utilisent des réseaux satellites
la première catastrophe spatiale la
collision entre deux objets d'envergure
mentionné précédemment impliqué le
satellite commercial
iridium 33 et cosmos 22,51 un satellite
de télécommunication rue se retirer du
service
iridium et cosmos étaient surveillés
mais personne n'a pu prévoir leur impact
ils savaient que ces objets allaient
passer près l'un de l'autre mais
personne ne pensait qu'il pouvait se
rencontrer ça a été une grave erreur de
calcul
après cette catastrophe
il est devenu évident que la
surveillance ne garantissait pas la
sécurité du fait d'un nombre trop élevé
de débris spatiaux incontrôlable en
orbite
alors tout va bien tout va bien
2011 des experts calculent
minutieusement l'orbité de la station
spatiale internationale et les risques
que peuvent représenter les des bruits à
bord de la station se trouve anton
chkaplerov et anatoli ivanichine et
daniel bard banques
c'était un dimanche à 4 ou 5 heures du
matin environ
mon collègue l'astronaute américain
daniel burban qu il est entré dans ma
cabine et m'a dit anthony ferons tout ce
que tu peux il faut évacuer
immédiatement vers le soyouz le centre
de contrôle de mission a repéré un
fragment d'un vieux satellites
météorologiques soviétique qui menaçait
d'entrer en collision avec les ss dans
les prochaines minutes
ce choc inattendu aurait abouti à une
catastrophe nous sommes allés dans le
vaisseau est géante refermer cette
trappe
je n'ai pas pris la peine de la fermer
complètement j'attendais pour voir ce
qui allait se passer si la station avait
été touché j'aurais verrouiller les
qu'outil pour sceller le vaisseau nous
nous serions désamarrée et serions
retourner sur terre s'il avait heurté le
vaisseau de nous en préserve
j'aurais pu ouvrir les outils on aurait
quitté scellé le vaisseau fillon serait
resté à bord de la station
en attendant de l'aide de la terre
repose chez eux heureusement une
collision entre l' iss est un gros
débris spatial n'a pas eu lieu ce jour
là mais le risque augmente et 2018
ce cap deroff et de nouveau à bord de l'
iss il écrit sur twitter
aujourd'hui nous avions un exercice de
décembre d'urgence à l'intérieur du
vaisseau soyouz en cas d'accident sur l'
iss par exemple s'il n'y a aucun moyen
d'éviter une collision avec des débris
spatiaux
j'ai fait mon premier vol en 2011 l'état
à l'époque l'idée de dévier la
trajectoire des débris sembler absurde
évidemment je faisais ça peut-être aux
deux fois en six mois c'est à dire
pendant toute la mission
maintenant on fait ça presque tous les
mois les débris les plus volumineux sont
des fragments de fusées et de vieux
satellite pesant plusieurs tonnes
ce sont des objets que les pilotes de
liesse à fresnes thèse qui v
mais les micros débris peuvent être
encore plus dangereux car impossibles à
détecter
il n'existe pas encore de solution
technique car ces objets sont très petit
et innombrables affirmatif il est
extrêmement difficile de les suivre tous
donc pour l'heure les cinq prochaines
années nous allons vivre avec ce
problème
sur cette photographie prise à bord de
l' iss vous pouvez voir l'impact d'un
débris spatial de 1 mm sur une fenêtre
les membres de la station enregistre
régulièrement ses cratères et on mesure
la profondeur un micro un pacte n'ont
remarqué peut être dangereux les
collisions lieu on les voit sur les
hublots
nous prenons des photos en 2d avec une
caméra et un équipement spécial les
vitres sont bien sûr multicouches l' iss
est très sérieusement blindés sa surface
est composée en majorité de plusieurs
couches pour pouvoir résister aux coûts
de ces microparticules de débris
spatiaux
[Musique]
vous pouvez observer la surface de
n'importe quel vaisseau spatial revenus
de l'espace dans la plupart des cas ils
sont couverts de cratères on a utilisé
des microscopes électroniques pour
déterminer si c'était l'oeuvre de
météorites ou de débris et l'examen a
montré que ces dégâts avaient été
causées par des particules artificiel la
première particules examiné comme l'a
montré l'analyse chimique s'est avéré
être une écailles de peinture
le nombre de nations ayant une activité
spatiale augmente les nouveaux arrivants
répète les erreurs des pionniers 2007 la
chine test une arme anti satellite 2019
l'inde fait des tests similaires
l'orbité terrestre basse est aujourd'hui
une arène de plus en plus encombré où ce
défi des ambitions militaires diverses
quand ils les militaires soutiennent
depuis longtemps que si une guerre
éclate
l'espace sera concernée au premier chef
par ce que les armées ont besoin de
systèmes de surveillance qui sont
contrôlées depuis la terre mais qui
dépendent de la communication satellite
et donc ces tests de missiles
antisatellites sont effectuées pour
déterminer comment prendre le dessus
dans le cas de guerre
tous les débris spatiaux repéré en
orbite sont répertoriés dans des
catalogues tenus par les militaires mais
aujourd'hui les débris représente une
menace pour toutes les infrastructures
de la planète militaires comme civils
il est trop dangereux de garder ses
catalogues secret les mêmes qu'à ce
match comme si un débris spatial touche
un satellite d'un pays cela pourrait
engendrer un conflit par exemple entre
deux puissances nucléaires et toute la
population de la planète en père et le
gris de plus en plus de nations sont
actives dans l'espace et le risque de
conflits internationaux duo débris
augmente des satellites orbite autour de
la planète depuis déjà 60 ans mais il
n'y a toujours pas de règles de
circulation établissant les
responsabilités en cas de collision avec
des débris spatiaux
à titre d'exemple disons qu'on s'est
accordé avec les états unis pour king
désorbiter un étage d'autres fusées on a
signé un contrat mais les parties ne se
sont pas entendus sur les
responsabilités vous comprenez et si
quelque chose ne se déroule pas comme
prévu au cours de cette mission cet état
j'ai détruit et de qui est ce la faute
la fédération de russie qui sera
coupable parce que à fuser et russe même
s'il étages a été détruit à cause d'une
erreur commise par l'exécuteur
2018 la mission aurait move débris a été
lancé une série d'essais ambitieux sur
orbite terrestre basse visant à tester
les idées les plus incroyables de
capture et d'élimination des débris
spatiaux sur terre de telles expériences
sont impossibles à réaliser le moyen le
plus évident est de les attraper
à l'aide d'un filet pour le moment nos
technologies ne permettent pas
d'intercepter les gros fragments pour
tester cette technologie des objets
imitant les débris spatiaux ont été
largués dans l'espace depuis les ss et
un collecteur les suivait un conteneur
avec un filet le filet est placé dans un
conteneur est attachée à des plombs qui
sont tirés vers l'extérieur par un
mécanisme à ressort il des plombs un
filet de la taille requise dans notre
cas 5 m puis il s'enroule autour du
sapin
cette vidéo a été filmée par les caméras
du collecteur le filet ne s'est pas
complètement déployé mais il a quand
même réussi à piéger les débris ça me
rappelle un peu les gladiateurs qui
jeter leurs filets dans l'arène et ce
n'était pas si facile de s'endetter
on a aussi eu un système absolument
infaillible ou les plombs se déployer et
renfermé le filet automatiquement
l'ensemble de l'opération n'a pas duré
plus de cinq secondes
un tel filet peut attraper des fragments
de débris de taille moyenne ne dépassant
pas les 2 mètres et pesant jusqu'à 2
tonnes et seulement à une distance de
quelques mètres dans des conditions
réelles
l'appareil doit arriver à hauteur d'un
débris spatial pour s'en approcher en
toute sécurité
la méthode la plus insolite mis à
l'essai dans le cadre du projet
d'enlèvement des déchets dans l'espace
et la capture de débris à l'aide d'un
harpon
mais cette technique soulève beaucoup de
questions c'est une bonne solution pour
les satellites qui ne tourne pas et
seulement s'il ya un endroit où on peut
fixer un harpon bien sûr il faut
s'assurer que le harpon ne frappe pas un
réservoir qui pourrait d'être sous
pression
bon un filet ainsi que des faisceaux
laser et même une voile spatiale tous
ces tests ont été menés avec succès dans
le cadre du projet remove débris mais
aucune des méthodes mentionné n'est pour
l'heure prête à être employés nous
voyons sur l'écran la trajectoire d'un
satellite artificiel terrestre il a été
lancé par une société italienne qui veut
devenir fournisseur de modules
récupérateur de débris pour tous les
satellites européens
une fois qu'un satellite aura accompli
sa mission le module le désorbitage en
l'espace de quelques heures afin qu'ils
puissent se consumer dans l'atmosphère
au lieu de devenir un déchet spatial
on a rempli toutes les tâches de
lancement mais on voulait faire encore
plus retiré que cette élite de son
orbite en peu de temps
mais cet objectif n'a pas été remplie le
module destiné à détruire les déchets
spatiaux est devenu lui même un débris
nous étions conscients des risques
nous savions que le moteur du module
était très puissant et que sa taille est
très petit qui s'est avéré que son mari
centre s'était légèrement décalée par
rapport aux boîtiers donc à propulsion
était trop forte qui on l'a renvoyé dans
la mauvaise direction
il mord d'eau précise c'est
incontrôlable satellite est supposée
entrer dans l'atmosphère est si consumer
dans quelques années il n'y a aucune
possibilité de capturer ce débris tout
ce qu'il reste à faire est observer et
attendre
l'humanité projette de créer un réseau
géant de satellite internet
mais les milliards d'utilisateurs ne
sont pas conscients que leur vie en
ligne est très vulnérable selon les
prévisions au moins une fois tous les
dix ans il y aura une collision en
orbite et ses accidents affecteront tout
le monde
[Musique]
la planète terre dans le futur
l'humanité a peut être appris à gérer
les débris en orbite il ne brûle pas ils
sont recyclés tout comme les déchets sur
terre les lancements constitue la partie
la plus chère de tout le programme
spatial mais certains proposent
d'intercepter un astéroïde le placer sur
orbite terrestre basse l'utilisaient
comme matière première est celle ci
serait produite dans l'espace mais bien
vous n'avez pas besoin de capturer des
astéroïdes car il y a beaucoup de
satellites retirés du service autour de
la terre et si on arrive à les collecter
puis à les recycler en les utilisant
comme matières premières cela coûtera
beaucoup moins cher
cheap de la construction d'une usine de
recyclage des déchets en orbite demeure
une perspective éloignée mais est une
étape inévitable de la conquête de
l'espace
ça ressemble peut être un scénario de
science-fiction mais ça ne l'est pas
c'est tout simplement une autre étape
logique de l'évolution de la technologie
aérospatiale autre voie l'idée de lancer
un satellite semblait tout aussi
utopique
grâce au système satellitaire nous
pouvons communiquer voyager à travers le
monde nous divertir restez informés
on ne se rend même pas compte que la
technologie spatiale est profondément
enraciné dans notre vie ni à quel point
cette technologie est fragile
voir si mal j'ai effectué trois vols
spatiaux en sept ans tout au long de
cette période j'ai pris des photos et
filmé des vidéos de différents endroits
de la planète
il y a des problèmes partout dans le
monde entier poste ces images sur les
réseaux sociaux pour appeler les gens à
y mettre fin et de faire de la terre un
endroit plus grands 06 autriche par
l'impact de l'humanité sur la planète
est immense l'homme a ouvert
l'anthropocène une nouvelle ère dans la
vie terrestre qui va encore durer
plusieurs millénaires
[Musique]
la terre change à cause de nous et nous
aussi devons changer pour elle
[Musique]